DRIVERS.
NOW THE TOP COP SUDDENLY
RESIGNED THIS WEEK JUST AS STATE
AUTHORITIES STEPPED IN TO
INVESTIGATE.
>> Reporter: LESS THAN 30
MINUTES AWAY FROM BIRMINGHAM
SITS THE SMALL TOWN OF
BROOKSIDE, ALABAMA.
IT IS A SMALL TOWN WITH NO
STOPLIGHTS NO, RETAIL STORES
OTHER THAN THE DOLLAR GENERAL.
THE TOWN HAS A LOT OF COMES TO
POLICE THE ONLY HIGHWAY GOING
THROUGH TOWN.
IT IS ABOUT THREE MILE LONG AND
HAS JUST OVER 1,200 RESIDENTS.
BUT THE POLICE HERE FEEL THE
NEED FOR AT LEFT A THREE
S.W.A.T. VEHICLES.
THEY ALSO HAVE A TANK WHICH
LOOKS BRAND NEW.
ACCORDING TO THE LOCAL MEDIA
OUTLET, BETWEEN 2018 AND 2020,
UNDER BROOKSIDE POLICE CHIEF
MIKE JONES, INCOME FROM FEES AND
FOR IF ITTURES INCREASED BY
640%.
THE OUTLET SAYS THE MONEY
AMOUNTS TO HALF THE TOWN'S TOTAL
INCOME, OR ROUGHLY 1.2 MILLION.
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE THEY TRIED
TO ROO INYOUR NAME?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: HE SAID HE IS ONE
OF THE COUNTLESS VICTIMS OF THE
ALLEGED POLICING FOR PROFIT.
IN 2019, HE SAYS HE WAS UNJUSTLY
PULLED OVER FOR HAVING TEMPORARY
PLATES ON HIS BRAND NEW CAR.
HE'S FILED A FEDERAL LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE TOWN OF BROOKSIDE
FOR DEFAMATION OF CHARACTER AND
FILING FALSE CHARGES.
>> THEY'RE POLICING FOR REVENUE.
THEY'RE PULLING PEOPLE OVER FOUR
BOGUS CHARGES.
>> Reporter: THIS COLLEGE
STUDENT SAID HER INACTION WITH
BROOKSIDE POLICE FELT LIKE A
SHAKEDOWN AFTER BEING PULLED
OVER FOR DRIVING WITHOUT HER
LIGHTS JUST BEFORE DUSK, SHE
SAID HER CAR WAS IMPOUMED AND
SHE WAS LEFT STRANDED ON THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD.
HER ATTORNEY SAID SHE WILL ALSO
SUE THE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
>> EVEN THOUGH I WAS PULLED
OVER.
I WAS FOLLOWING THE LAWS.
ROAD.
>> Reporter: THE JEFFERSON
COUNTY OFFICE SAID THERE'S BEEN
A SLEW OF COMPLAINTS AGAINST THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THIS WEEK THE POLICE CHIEF MIKE
JONES SUDDENLY RESIGNED.
WE WENT TO BROOKSIDE TO TRY TO
TALK TO WHO IS IN CHARGE NOW.
>> THE TOWN OF BROOKSIDE DOESN'T
HAVE A NEW POLICE CHIEF?
WE'RE TOLD THEY DIDN'T HAVE A
NEW CHIEF.
THE POLICE GAVE US THIS
STATEMENT.
THIS WILL CONFIRM THAT MIKE
JONES RESIGNED FOR THE TOWN OF
BROOKSIDE SINCE THIS INVOLVES A
PERSON HE WILL MATTER, THE TOWN
HAS NO FURTHER COMMENT.
BROOKSIDE'S MAYOR WAS IN THE
OFFICE BUT HE DECLINED OUR
REQUEST FOR AN INTERVIEW.
HE HANDED US THIS STATEMENT.
IN PART SAYING, TO INVESTIGATE
AN AND ADDRESS THE ISSUES RAISED
BY OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT, THE
TOWN OF BROOKSIDE REQUESTED THE
ALABAMA POLICE OFFICERS'
STANDARDS AND TRAINING
COMMISSION PERFORM A PERFORMANCE
AUDIT OF THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND THE OFFICERS.
THE TOWN CONTINUES TO
INVESTIGATE THESE ISSUES AND
WILL TAKE ANY OTHER APPROPRIATE
ACTION THAT MAY BE DETERMINED
NECESSARY.
WITH THE SOCIAL JUSTICE
NONPROFIT ALABAMA APPLESEED SAID
THEY DON'T GENERATE ENOUGH TO
GET THAT REVENUE ANOTHER WAY.
>> AND THE PATH OF LEA